all right so as I said in the post I
don't have to eill a m but you have to
remember that the technique is supposed
to be operating more energetically than
it is
physically and as a
result external movements can be greatly
reduced okay and um because my ultimate
goal our ultimate goal is the
reconciliation of the two
minds that skill of what that feels like
and what that is is actually determining
what how much of a angle or an external
movement you do or don't do once you
feel the two minds reconcil you don't
want to keep doing gross external
movements also martially so going from
the physical component perspective
martially the bigger your movements are
the less Marshal they're going to be
they have to be small because time and
space is a luxury in human behuman
violence okay so a lot of times when I'm
left to my own self uh there's very
little movement that an observer can see
but yet the reaction is exactly the same
in the UK's body and that's why okay so
it looked to some that there's one
version where I grossly bring his elbow
in and then come
around I'll do it one more time
to some it look like there's a version a
I go to the right he goes to the left
the elbow comes in it passes me and then
I seek the fire spiral
okay all I need to understand is not
that angle deviation looks with a a
right knee over here followed by my left
leg adjusting I don't want to understand
angles def flexion as always the elbow
in like that angle of deviation means
that I've cleared the line that's all it
means I've cleared the line of attack so
as in the video if I take the back leg
and step I've cleared the line so he's
here here's his linear line of attack
and as it's coming straight at me if I
deviate the back leg and I have done
angle deviation
I don't need to
go one two I don't need to do that so
often times I don't
sometimes as he's coming in and that was
all I did I didn't move at all but I did
use angle deviation that's even higher
level so same way here angle deflection
is not the gross
movement as it manifested angle of
deflection is
he cannot come back the other way that's
what I'm trying to
do so it can be bring the elbow
in but I can make it so for example uh
go to the right if you want you see that
would be the
iupi this way he can go to the
right okay and as he pushes and I locked
his elbow out
he can't go to the
right so he pushes and I lock the elbow
up it's very
subtle boom that's it you can't go to
the right now can't go to the
right so it looks like this is one
version and this is the other version
but it's not it's not he still can't go
to the right do you guys see that okay
so a lot of times
I go ahead and take
advantage of this
smaller angle of cancellation and angle
of
deflection because in doing so you're
going to get a bigger
movement it's as if his
arm just becomes a big throwing
PL so we're going and
that would be exactly what I'm talking
about and that version is not another
version it's just a more internalized
version not an external version it's not
plan be now when it comes to Ura
Ura
requires that there's some push back on
him right at some point he I have to
feel that
it's not I do the same
thing and then I go over here cuz there
was no push back and you can see that is
the OTA
opening that's where I should have
entered cuz now I have this
mistake at some degree you'll feel oh
crap don't try to enter on that that's
where you turn
so if we train
Kona you have a couple options your UK
recognizes when you're going to do Ur
like for example you did tuot now comes
Ura they provide that Catalyst to make
tactical sense of the
Ura um or you specifically work on Ura
hey jam up the Ulta entry and now we're
going to work on only Ura uh again only
tradition and culture says two and two
these are skills that you should just be
working on them however you need to
develop your own skill set so you don't
have to always do OT every time you do
Ura which we don't train like that but
another thing you can do is I'll modify
in Keon the entry slightly so instead of
projecting him where I know he's not
going to be able to stop the OT
I project him more around me boom this
way he coming more around me you see
making this turn the ulted turn quite
difficult to do but not the Ura
turn it's not ideal because
energetically it's artificial but
mechanically it'll help teach some
somebody where is thei on the UR version
okay it's not where the OT version is
all right so again one I kind of bring
him more past me more past
me he goes away from
me or not he goes more round more
round
okay but it doesn't have anything to do
with there is an angle of deflection
regardless on his arm contrary to my
angle of deviation if I move to the
right internally on the subtler version
he still can't go to the right making it
still a sound principle and really the
same technique not two different
variations okay all
right I'm going to try try a different
explanation or additional one so
remember in kihon Wasa you're doing a
prescribed energetic purification ritual
and then the assumption is that the
hands uh move the Y cheat the the hands
circulate the Yang and Yin okay uh and
so you do do these kind of gross
movements but if as you're working from
the mystical aspect the spiritual
component or the physical martial
component you don't need to make those
big movements okay which means you could
do your energetic purification rituals
with small movements as I said I often
do okay um let me do a KN Feld okay and
so as I as I come
around the full movement is going to be
uh a knife edge down fingers down okay
and I hold this
on so his hand can't slide around okay
the full
movement and if you come around you can
see that it makes his elbow drop
okay
so the architecture the full
architecture itself if he lifts his
elbow as he would if he had to stand up
makes the pain happen you see that so
that's an
external
uh manipulation of how much movement in
That Elbow okay but as you come around
here is nowhere near the movement do you
see no nowhere near the movement and try
to lift your
elbow okay so what's happening is is
usually on the external version people
just send inertia momentum into the
parts they're
touching but even on on the full
movement of the kihon waza so feel that
and now feel this you see so the energy
is going up the arm and taking away the
ability for things to move so if I'm
here you kind of roll your shoulder
around you see I send the energy up your
arm do you see gets a little harder a
little harder you can start lightening
it up a little harder and I'm just in
that body now okay and that's how I send
energy from wherever I'm touching and I
send it into the center
so energy has to be able to to Traverse
the the human body okay and you can
achieve the same thing I can't move my
elbow I can't rotate a full un impinged
360° of the shoulder without actually
having to stop the shoulder do you do
you get it and that's what you're
doing in this one so it looks like I'm
doing Cha's version this way but I'm
not because even as I'm moving and even
if this as this hand is coming this way
the energy is you can I'll demonstrate
what I'm doing grossly it's going like
this you see there's a turn there that
makes That Elbow come in and so he's
going to let me get to the outside of
him and then I let him get past me and
then I do the
technique so if you look it looks like
his arm is like that but there's an
energy that's spiraling up his arm that
without moving it like this prevents him
from turning it this way which is
exactly what you do in the gross
movement where you make the elbow come
in okay all
right thank you very much thank you